this week we've got horny grannies who
get into that kind of poll that's a real
thing though what the old people people
get horny ah I hope that [ __ ] disappears
like a mother dudes die Hornaday that's
why viagra so like so lucrative
yeah dude dudes die and then even after
they're dead for six hours they have a
boner
that's how always like the only time
that it will work by the end of life how
dare you how dare you damn dude police
TIFF just made fun of my old dick horny
grannies what else and police talking Oh
mud run
I've read the police talk yeah I heard
mud run didn't you do a Spartan races
let's do another one yeah let's do it
well I did that was my thing last year's
I wanted to do all of them and test
matters yeah well Spartan races cuz then
it's pretty fun they have these three
it's like a sprint a super and in a
beast so it's like a five mile race an
eight mile race and half a marathon
which is like 13 14 miles and I was like
I do those three and then you can
complete this triangle because each time
you finish a race you get like a piece
of the triangle how cool yeah it makes
it fun it's like a McDonald's monopoly
piece yeah I'm very fulfilled by rewards
this - it's like an imaginary thing yeah
I'm so cynical I'm like what the [ __ ]
that's it yeah like I just get a little
corner yeah I don't know I'm sick I'm a
simpleton like yeah like that make me
happy as fun that always works for
everybody that's not why Yelp works you
know what I mean you're a Yelp elite oh
yeah yeah yeah y'all believe but that's
the same cause of them yes yeah people
like being rewarded no matter what it is
people like being rewarded for it I used
to collect the badges they yell bad
exact was my [ __ ] I was like I gotta
take it to every airport do those Disney
pen people are pretty [ __ ]
oh yeah oh speaking of my [ __ ]
roommates sister is a Disney pin person
really what's Disney pin they have all
you collect these Disney pins they like
an ice cream store will have a specific
Disney Penny she made him wait in line
at 5 a.m. in the morning to collect one
of those pins dude have you seen have
you've seen them before Joe we're here
at Disney you see weird looking metal
some sort of yeah
bunch of Disney pins they say if a
Disney employee has pins and you see the
Disney employee and you want one of
their pins they have to trade you yeah
they do
yeah yeah we did you trade though yeah
the trade yes like I give you a pen you
give yeah yeah but they can't refuse
your trade really don't wear one it's
like a little culture right so like if I
see TIFF and she's walking around with
pins we could trade I'll be like oh do
you want to trade me this for this and
it's like Pokemon or whatever well the
cards and stuff well let's get into
these stories Oh for the first story
there was this elderly home this nursing
home that had some entertainment for the
older ladies gorgey a stripper Magic
Mike
so they reportedly kept asking for a
visit from scantily clad Butler's so
that's what they got the women that like
the residents they would invite their
granddaughters or the younger ones there
just family members okay I like that one
in the yellow do the dudes get the dicks
touched in [ __ ] yeah I don't know
probably right is that the equivalent of
like grab the [ __ ] for some extra she
actually died after that she had a heart
attack
look at that smile and son my grandma
has Alzheimer's and she had a she
thought she had a relationship with one
of the grandkids versus Oh Mike my
grandma kept thinking kept calling dibs
on her own grandchildren she had
pictures of all the boys for
grandchildren on her fridge and she'd be
like you liked that one
he's mine and she'd be like I have dibs
on him have you all time yeah by heat so
does his grandma right I would be like
on skype with her and then my mom's like
Oh she'll walk up she's like who's this
handsome yeah yeah cuz they think that
they're young they like revert back to
high school or whatever cuz my mom she
my grandma thought my mom was her mom
and she'd be like mom I'm busy
yeah and she would be like she was
checking out Steve like who are you yeah
and like sounds like you know I'm not
[ __ ] interested she kicked me out of
the house one time because she thought I
was flirting with my grandpa
she thought she thought that I was
taking it trying to take her man
granddaughter but she also called my
grandpa she's like I don't know who he
is I think he owns the place but he
always tries to have sex with me the
nurse gave my grandma sponge bath and
she said that she had an intimate moment
with him in the bathroom
so she in her mind she was like getting
some sexual pleasures but he was just
[ __ ] washing her he was just doing
his job that he hates oh yeah so this
the activities coordinator hired a
company called hunks and Trunks and then
so the eleven female residents they were
just have at the time of their lives I
would pay to get my grandma [ __ ] this
happened to the UK boiler not even
getting [ __ ] no but if they do the
extra I'll just be like and then she
likes him I'll be like you know hook her
up dude do you think honking trunks was
like just like sitting there like man
we're going to close the business nobody
[ __ ] go on those honks with trunks
like how many how are you does it
business like that get I wonder yeah cuz
what they did is they served a
three-course meal and then we gave them
each a massage that's tight
be really gentle with the ladies
bachelorette party is anywhere where
there's like older married women
involved we have a friend who's obsessed
with thunder down under'
he's like that's gone dude she's not
she's not with us anymore dmg di Gary
yeah she likes gay guys well no she's
like that's what I thought too but turns
out they're not is she super long super
woke to it and she's a only no that's
what all dammit oh she's married so she
got involved at Lake during her
bachelorette party they took her to
Thunder so she's never done it before
but she saw the light yes I wish I
[ __ ] knew this before
gonna get married everyone trying to get
everyone into it now why so what they
keep going back cuz she thought it was
gay guys - and now she's like no it's
like no the straight is she she just the
things she describes are like oh my god
I sometimes forget that that doesn't
happen to other people
yes she's like no you don't understand
they'll they'll pick you up and they can
just throw you on the bed you're like oh
I guess there's a bed on stage and so
they pick one girl and so she got chosen
because it was her bachelor he's so hot
and so like yeah you see he's picks me
up is her husband week it's her husband
like a four-footed like frail little man
I know or she just heavy think think
1960s Batman he's Robin Oh and is she
like more like you know Sam like honey
Boo Boo's mom so she's like like she's
probably mice about you and it would
1960s Batman but how was it was that did
he get you horny when you want her to
meet you know exactly that's what they
actually pulled me up on saves Tammy
wrapping up in a lasso and then movie
like they were facing me at the end of
it and like they pretended to take off
their chaps and so it seemed like they
were gonna show me some dick but then
they had like a little soft cover were
you disappointed did you want to go to a
strip club a regular one you see titties
everywhere everywhere JD's cities
everywhere ass titties ass titties yeah
you go to a guy strip club neither titty
serious but that's what I'm saying girls
don't really get horny from that [ __ ]
it's more just like the fun well I don't
know TIFF looks like she she might she
said she wants you I mean oh right win
cuz like they built up the whole
performance and I was there like you
were blue balls so we're just like okay
and then now that well what if it was
like a tiny penis what I've done
anything for you um I think it was just
the fact that I would get he had a taboo
aspect of it
of like oh we're being bad you say
you're saying it didn't get you horny
because you didn't get to see today no
I'm saying like I was getting turned on
up until the point where they were about
to show me some dick and then they did
it and then I was just like blue bald
fat oh it's like sexy dude and he farts
in front yeah he just doesn't joke yeah
cuz like had a sock yeah we're not an
actual soccer look like flesh-colored
like they were like tucked in it was
like a thong okay damn I know huh that's
best sucks the next story
there was this drunk time man who had
just finished half a bottle of liquor
and he decided at 5:00 in the morning to
just go out for a run so he was jogging
and that's when he fell into the sea of
mud and he had to have health Oh
in order to get out was it like
quicksand maybe did he was so hungover
he's all drunk and he's like you know
what it's like let's take a picture of
that's so funny that's a picture if I've
ever seen a picture we're the first
sentence that you see here from the guy
is while I was drinking yeah that's the
big it looks like there will be blood
where they the oil goes everywhere and
they're all trying to go what are the
shadiest beaches ever pier he look no he
was running on top and he fell off so he
was drinking I was gonna saying he
looked at the mud is like I can run over
this yeah and so they needed a like lift
him out I know exactly what that [ __ ]
was thinking too he was like you know
what I need it looks like some man
like you getting a nice like mud
treatment like in gonna be smooth us
books in his living room like this is
what this guy was thinking he was saying
New Year's resolution tie New Year's
resolution I need to get fit and he
decided to go out and achieve his dream
drinking inspired well he's saying that
he was smoking right before smoking too
he was smoking he took and running no no
but he was running at least voters like
that was a bad decision I got a rush no
he was running first and then he stopped
to smoke a cigarette and then he took a
wrong step and then he felt running oh
this is bad idea and he [ __ ] smokes
it he's like like there's this video
[ __ ] you just think like talking and
he's still drunk
I think you're like tip his hand back in
the mud like nice and comfy then when
they rescue him on this lift thing so
you see how there's two guys right and
there's like that opening where he came
in through so they're finally lifting
him up and I think the two guys were
just so tired of like getting off
they're just like Oh like not really
looking at him and it's not at one point
where he was like leaning forward like
he was about to fall off again they're
like is why do people litter a whole
entire water cooler and just leaves
leave it in the [ __ ] ocean like
that's [ __ ] up man
that's like that [ __ ] big-ass
construction worker water cooler [ __ ]
where you can like dispense it bottom
yeah those things are expensive but
they're sturdy yeah when I see trash at
the beach I [ __ ] shed a tear have you
ever been to Bali no is there a lot
trash yeah block yeah but they like it's
like they like all the trash from the
city just like it's dumped there I
wonder if it's even Indonesian trash
like what if it's like yeah Vietnam
trash or something I know right it could
be we are in Maui and then they're
explaining how like on this Beach a lot
of Japan
trash ends up there oh that's
interesting yeah it was weird too
because that we had just come from
Singapore where it's like illegal to
litter you know well it's illegal to
litter everywhere but like you know they
get little to gum you can get really
find like crazy yeah and Singapore you
can get fine for chewing gum so it was
super clean in Singapore and then we go
to Bali and Bali is like really nice
looking I was like an island it's
beautiful and then but then there's like
trash on all the beaches and then
there's signs saying like keep our be
just cleaning and like right over piles
of trash dude it's crazy and in
Singapore like it looks like they
vacuumed pavement yeah like it's like
how the [ __ ] do you get a dirt it's
crazy man no in Japan - it was like that
it's like Japan's really clean Wow from
an early age people clean up after
themselves or they're suppose they know
it's just the right thing to do part of
the religious custom too is that they do
these little in Bali they do these
little like offerings offerings yeah and
so that's just everywhere so littering
is a part of the religion not in front
of all the entrances to all their homes
and stuff and they put new ones out
every day right
is it biodegradable or is it like made
out of like it's probably biodegradable
over time yeah but it don't look like a
bro it's like taking some time bro Japan
was clean until you threw up all over -
yeah you threw up in Japan yeah yeah all
over the place yeah I think it was
emotional distress because when we found
out about brown and I just could not
stop crying that day that was just
quitting I bet it was cuz you were dry
Regina no I didn't drink at all I was
just crying the whole day and then like
after like we were trying to eat dinner
and then I was just like I didn't even
see you guys
that [ __ ] was tough I get that oh that's
why I didn't see you puke but that's
okay
you could barf in that's how much I love
brown was that a dog was it was it the
moment when you puke and then the guy
was trying to help you yeah okay subway
yeah I think I was there for that moment
or something you weren't we told you
about it cuz you had Isaac okay
Oh
all right before our last story there is
this video the safety education video
that's gone viral
so apparently students high school
students in Texas must watch this video
before graduating
due to this new Texas law and it went
viral because this video was shot so
poorly it was acting was so bad but
that's the best part about in a 16
minutes long but that's a good length
for bad acting - all right the longer
the better that's like when we watch the
trap deposit oh yeah why can't this be
forever oh yeah like the worst these
videos are the more hilarious it is and
then the more memorable - yeah yeah it's
kind of cool cuz then in like ten years
everyone has that bit of nostalgia like
remember that video we used to have to
watch and then they can't make jokes
it's like Neal Breen dude double down
starring Neal Breen look it up one of
the funny funniest videos we'll ever
find and the acting is so terrible he's
a real-estate investor in Las Vegas and
he just takes all of his money and puts
it into these film projects that he
writes produces stars direct they're
hilarious dude so I think local
commercials like furniture stories our
dealerships they are so genius cuz you
just it doesn't it burns into your brain
it does I also like a kind of oh you
know five out of ten looking chick who's
like we're available now call now yeah a
sex education video is probably the best
too though it was all good stupid
situations or something awkward topic
the team actors in it they're already
feeling awkward because Randy do you
have a condom we're not gonna need that
I have great control hey now all of a
sudden the [ __ ] fades away and
they're just pregnant I should have used
the god
I was so freaked out by drug videos when
there would be like everyone's gonna
offer you drugs like hey man why'd she
want to take a hit I know I always
thought some kid who like was where
nineties clothes was gonna offer me
drugs so here to go to high school I've
never seen those in middle school and I
was so scared to go to high school cuz I
thought everyone was gonna offer me
dropping those ecstasy videos you
remember that one video where there was
this girl she was in a club and then she
ends up being on a canoe and then they
dumped her in the hell yeah I've never
seen that how is that cuz I was like
holy [ __ ] they wanted to keep the party
going I just remember this is your brain
is your brain on and then I looked at
the eggs and I was like that looks
delicious
yeah and that did it looked like a good
perfectly cooked day it's a nice sunny
up egg I did the only video that maybe
like really worried about drugs was that
was like the [ __ ] about II just because
I know twofers it Oh deep oh yeah it was
like oh [ __ ] you know a name like that
should kind of freak me out because when
you see it in person when they use not
interested yeah because of these go to
raves all the time like back in the day
before raves are like popular you had to
know somebody to know somebody to go
into this [ __ ] like random well
Sacramento's like these barns and [ __ ]
yeah you know so you would see people OD
all the time on the ocean this is
[ __ ] real dude
can you imagine seeing a commercial for
E it's like this guy is just sitting
here but but he but for him he's in an
f-117 tomahawk like like cruise missile
or some [ __ ] like he's flying a [ __ ]
jet fighter like in space it's a
hallucinogen you're so sweet I don't
know baby no he is the one that makes
you feel good when you're like touching
each other if you take enough
take enough it can get there hunt your
mouth your eyes so lucid so why is this
like video going viral and stuff so
Texas has this new law called the
Community Safety Education Act and so
that's what's requiring this video to be
a mandatory curriculum and type of
public high schools because they're
saying that they want to mend the
relationship between the community and
police especially after all these like
shootings and all these things that
maybe [ __ ] I know my rights what
you know I mean they're just teaching it
like soon they're pretty much they want
everyone to understand what is expected
from civilian where you're being pulled
over and what does a cop or what should
you expect from a cop - so it's like a
mutual i I actually am on board with
that effect it wasn't all shitty in the
video because it's so scary getting
pulled over
I remember getting things like don't
panic yeah I would like have a mini
heart attack every time I got pulled
over and it was I don't never knew what
I did wrong and I'm like what am I doing
wrong and then I don't know where to
pull over there like pull over and I
always pull over on the wrong side and
that's for like good at the gas station
this video would actually help you
because they tell you exactly where you
should pull and then they're like have
you been drinking I'm like I'm 16 I
don't drink
oh I want to make a video where like
it's like all the stuff you shouldn't do
when you get pulled over like you get
pulled over you like what the [ __ ] you
want [ __ ]
yes hey I'll take a cheeseburger do
fries in always want to do that [ __ ]
never had the ball never had the balls
yeah they're telling you like you should
keep your hands on the stairs oh yeah
like don't like rummage when the cops
approaching you and then built they also
have like this Q&A portion in that video
where there's civilians asking questions
like why do cops do this like why do
they make me pull all my windows down
and then the answer is like well you
know it's for the safety of the cop
because they don't know if there's
someone in your back seat if it's too
dark and it can't see then like they'll
give you answers like why do they make
me do this well so they don't think that
it's like a personal
HAC because of whatever yeah yeah do you
know the rummaging thing I always
rummage because I know they're gonna ask
me for my license and registration and I
can never find my registration forever I
don't like so I'm like I gotta get this
[ __ ] prepared I always I always tell the
police ah just be like okay I'm gonna
reach into my back pocket with my right
hand very slowly don't shoot me
yeah it's exactly let me tell you the O
in the video like you should with what
I'm gonna go read from [ __ ] I'm going
for it put my fist up and then I am
going to release my middle finger sir
I'm reaching for my Constitution United
States of America because I have a right
to pursuit of happiness and this is not
making me very happy
yeah that's not the law whatever it's
different for guys too because like you
know I don't know I've never done any of
that stuff and and I just I guess I
don't really look threatening I think
well statistically how often do women
shoot at cops right that's what I'm
saying I wonder if it's different for
guys oh yeah there's yeah cuz like I
full and gotten pulled over before and
the cop you know they go in front of you
to pull over yeah they he drove past me
he saw me and then he just sped off what
I was all pulled over and I'm like do I
stay here is he coming back at more
important emergency and you were there
for about a week he didn't tell me what
to do I'm still here first time I ever
got pulled over I didn't know what the
[ __ ] to do so I pulled in like a [ __ ]
shopping centre and stopped and then the
cop like had his hand on his gun the
whole time he's like sir put your hands
on the steering wheel place your heads
with the steering wheel and then I did I
was like oh [ __ ]
and then he's like he's and then he saw
how young I was I was like 19 and he's
like he's like you gotta place your
hands on the [ __ ] steering one man
he's like for all I know he's like
you're the River City killer I was like
that River City killer he made up his
own killer date up some killers my sexy
right River City when I was at UCR those
dude at this church just really [ __ ]
bad luck I guess there was a dude that
killed the cop or something and he was
like roaming around but it was like a
asian dude and they [ __ ] literally
rolled up on the dude put guns out and
slammed into the floor everything got
arrested
like literally some real [ __ ] and he was
so [ __ ] upset and we saw the picture
of the guy and it was like did you
actually look exactly like I mean how
can you blame him did he look identical
to the guy
yes it was just the day that he shaved
his [ __ ] head - well like your friend
God look just like that guy he was the
day he shaved his [ __ ] head because
he lost his Church bet and he was like
like some kind of Church bet he has
Sheamus [ __ ] Singh Kham episode like the
most pure guy like lost his church that
he was one of the [ __ ] church leaders
but you say Church bed like it's a
common thing I'm like Church but yeah
you know like that I need a church boy
you're right it's like you do like
stupid [ __ ] bats it's very night calm
[ __ ] you know so you know if you do
shave your [ __ ] head in the sitcom
they would call it a church but so you
know that that character is a good
person
yeah they got swapped with a bad guy I
say Church bit because like you would do
like stupid [ __ ] like it's like in
Korean churches like you're like doing
[ __ ] wrist slaps or some [ __ ] like
that or you know the pants them or some
[ __ ] so it's like oh if you do shave
your [ __ ] head it's very soft [ __ ]
dude me and Nikki I've never been more
offended me and Nikki got invited to a
wedding and we had to sit through a
[ __ ] hour and a half mass yes
starving yes and then they didn't even
have the decency to have a [ __ ] paid
and an open bar there like it was a cash
bar and not only that drinks were $12
Wow
so I was like wow I just went to a
[ __ ] Church and now I don't even get
to drink ideals meals and we couldn't
use our card to pay for it like you had
to have always got the [ __ ] cash on
you this was a wedding
no one has cash anymore this is a
wedding and at least have the decency
and your invite to be like guess what
it's a cash bring cash right
[Music]